bob sage came to my house for dinner did
he really i did bob saget um podcast
and when we when we logged off and you
know i found out i said you're playing
in indy i live here he's like why don't
i come to your house for dinner and i'm
like what the [ __ ] you know i'm like you
wanna go to my [ __ ] house for
dinner and so he really threw me off and
i'm like okay
and so i didn't really know if he was
gonna come wow so and at the time i'm in
atlanta trying to buy a house and get
our stuff together i had a gig and i had
to get rid of that date that bob said
that thursday because i was not gonna
tell bob say he could not come to my
[ __ ] house so i just i went home and
i cleaned up i called the housekeeping
and i was like what the [ __ ] is going on
i have a really famous person coming to
the house but i can't tell y'all who it
is because i didn't know if bob sagan
were gonna show the [ __ ] up like you
know how famous people stand you up oh
yeah and then they was like well who's
coming and i would never tell them who
came and i just said wait till they ring
the doorbell and everybody trying to
figure out [ __ ] who coming he rings
the doorbell he got flowers in his hand
and why they they was like bob sage
[Laughter]
oh my god and we sat down and i wish i'd
have videoed the whole thing when i tell
you he was so [ __ ] funny and you know
you're thinking bob sang it you know the
clean bumps take it from the sick um
corny as [ __ ] you know you know but i've
seen his stand up i knew his standup was
funny i just did he was so [ __ ] quick
with it he was like just cracking the
[ __ ] he had us cracking up like
seriously and then we my son barbecue
because my son junebug can barbecue
really well so i was like jumbo you
going to barbecue and gary ellen is
going to make this like who the [ __ ]
shut the [ __ ] up i said just cook the
food and i can't cook so
we made this barbecue and i bought
steaks and you know i'm like i don't
know what the [ __ ]
you know rich people eat or how they eat
so i just went out about the best of
everything and um
bob sagan ate a plate he's like oh my
god this [ __ ] is so [ __ ] good he got
up and when he fixed himself another
place
sat out and then he did i was like hold
on bob you want to buy grocery
[ __ ]
he's like he's been a long time since i
had food that's good miss bella what the
[ __ ] have you been and he was there for
about four or five hours and we laughed
at that table and we talked and that's
my that's my most memorable moment with
him wow that's wild that's amazing huh
yeah and your family your kids were
there too
my whole family was there it sure was i
flew i flew uh my the girl who do my
hair and i was like he might not come
because i told her who he was but i
didn't tell my family and we just waited
he wrung that door but he got in an uber
damn he got out the [ __ ] uber like a
nice uber a regular one it was a regular
little uber i don't even think the
person who picked bob sag it up knew
they would bob said he had a mask on oh
yeah
yeah
damn and and so we take some pictures
and i post them and everybody's like bob
sagan was in our neighborhood
oh that's my most memorable i tell you
when um i found out he passed i couldn't
stop crying yeah because it was such a
building relationship like bob sage
would literally
text me in the middle of now how are you
doing bada and i just talked to him
because you know i asked bob to be on my
show and i was my show was on bt plus
and pair my plus and you know i know bob
ain't never been on bt so i said i'm
gonna ask him you know i said would you
come and play you know a role on the
trees like [ __ ] yeah i'm there so we
were literally talking about him you
know doing a role on the show yeah and
um
um the week the week he died i just text
him and say send it up he's telling me
who to reach out to and i got you pat
i'm gonna do it
and i was leaving a falcon game and my
son called and said they said bob sega
died and i called and was no answer and
i was like this can't be real
and i lit i i literally [ __ ] cried i
was like because i really liked it he
was so [ __ ] genuine he was just a
genuine guy and i'm the type of person
like i don't give a [ __ ] who you are or
what you've done
if you're a good person then i [ __ ] with
you yeah and he was a good person wow
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy
two
options watch one this one or this one